COMPLICATED, COLLAB RAYORS OFTEN
BECAME PARTNERS.
RANDI KAYE LOOKS BACK.
♪
>> SHE WAS HIS DRUMMER, THEN
EVENTUALLY HIS FIANCE.
SHEILA E.SAID SOMEWHERE IN THE
MIDDLE OF A EUROPEAN TOUR PRINCE
MOUTHED TO HER MARRY ME.
SHE SAID YES.
>> I WAS WALKING ON STAGE TO
INTRODUCE MYSELF, HE WAS IN THE
MIRROR, HE SHOOK MY HAND, HE
GOES I KNOW WHO YOU ARE.
I WENT HUH?
HE SAID I HAVE BEEN FOLLOWING
YOUR CAREER.
>> SHE LATER SIGNED A CONTRACT
WITH HIS PRODUCTION COMPANY AND
PRINCE OVERSAW HER FIRST ALBUM
"THE GLAMOROUS LIFE."
♪
>> ANOTHER PRINCE'S LOVES WAS
HIS PROTEGE, DENISE MATTHEWS,
FORMER MODEL WHO BECAME A SINGER
BEGAN DATING HIM IN THE 1980s.
JET MAGAZINE SAID SHE CLAIMED
PRINCE WAS THE ONLY MAN SHE EVER
TRULY LOVED.
PRINCE CALLED HER VANITY, BUILT
THE GROUP VANITY 6 AROUND HER,
ENCOURAGING HER TO RECORD SONGS
LIKE "NASTY GIRL."
AFTER SEVERAL YEARS TOGETHER,
THEY SPLIT.
AFTER SHE DIED, HE DEDICATED A
SONG TO HER ON TOUR.
MADONNA HAD A RELATIONSHIP OF
SORTS WITH PRINCE.
THEY DATED BRIEFLY IN 1985.
PRINCE LATER HELPED PRODUCE HER
1989 ALBUM "LIKE A PRAYER" WHICH
HE WAS ALSO FEATURED ON.
THEY SANG A DUET.
"LOVE SONG."
YEARS LATER, THE FRIENDSHIP
SOURED, THOUGH JUST LAST FALL,
SHE ATTENDED ONE OF HIS LATE
NIGHT JAM SESSIONS AT PAISLEY
PARK IN MINNESOTA.
AFTER HER OWN CONCERT, GRABBED A
VIP SEAT AS PRINCE TOOK THE SAGE
FOR HIS OWN 2:00 A.M. SHOW.
PRINCE MET THE STUNNING CARMELO
ENELECTRA WHEN SHE WAS 18.
THEY DATED AWHILE, PRINCE
PRODUCED A RAP ALBUM FOR HER.
IT WAS PRINCE DECIDED SHE SHOULD
CHANGE HER NAME TO CARMEN.
SHE RECALLED HOW IT HAPPENED.
>> THE NAME OF THE SONG IS
CALLED CARMEN ON TOP.
MY NAME IS TARA, SO I WAS
CONFUSED.
I LOVED THE SONG, I LOVED IT.
BUT HE SAID UH-UH.
YOU'RE NOT TARA, YOU'RE NOT
TARA, YOU'RE CARMEN.
>> PRINCE'S FIRST WIFE CALLED
HIM HER FIRST CRUSH.
>> I GOT MARRIED WHEN I WAS 22.
I CAN'T REALLY PINPOINT A TIME
WHEN IT BECAME ROMANTIC.
I JUST THINK IT EVOLVED, YOU
KNOW, THROUGH THE HEAVENS, I
DON'T KNOW.
>> AS SHE TELLS IT, THEY FIRST
MET WHEN HE ASKED HER BACK STAGE
AT ONE OF HIS CONCERTS.
SHE WAS 16.
SHE EVENTUALLY JOINED HIS BAND,
AND THE TWO STARTED SERIOUSLY
DATING.
THEY MARRIED VALENTINE'S DAY IN
1996.
PRINCE WAS SMITTEN, SO IT IS NO
SURPRISE, SHE INSPIRED MANY OF
HIS SONGS, INCLUDING "THE MOST
BEAUTIFUL GIRL IN THE WORLD."
BE. THE MARRIAGE WASN'T MEANT T-
THE COUPLE LOST TWO CHILDREN,
ONE SON LIVED FOR ONLY A WEEK,
THE OTHER WAS A MISCARRIAGE.
SHE TOLD REPORTERS IT WAS HARD
TO MOVE FORWARD AS A COUPLE
AFTER THAT.
THEY SPLIT IN 1998 AND DIVORCED
IN 2000.
PRINCE TRIED MARRIAGE AGAIN IN
2001 WHEN HE MARRIED MANUELA
TEST AT THAT LEAN EE.
THEY MET WHILE WORKING FOR HIS
CHARITABLE FOUNDATION.
HE WAS 43, SHE WAS 24.
WHEN THEY TIED THE KNOT, THE
MAGAZINE REPORTED HIS NEW WIFE
TOOK HIS LAST NAME NELSON, WHICH
THE SINGER NEVER USED.
THIS MARRIAGE REPORTEDLY